well there it goes
foreign
I'd like to introduce representative
Alvin C who's sitting in with us today
from Transportation thank you for being
one of our members is testifying in
another room so we're going to go
through a couple of these bills and
hopefully he will join us shortly
representative McHugh
the first bill 141 HB 141 relative to
dogs on hiking trails and state parks
I'd like to recognize representative
Vale for emotion representative
would you like me to speak to my motion
okay uh you're right the second do we
have a sec
you may speak to your motion
representative there
yes
um thank you Mr chair
um I move itl on the bill relative to
dogs hiking on hiking trails and state
parks what we learned in the testimony
is that in the state parks
the division already allows dogs off
leash and under the control of their
Handler under their administrative rules
and our ability their ability to tailor
their administrative roles is really
important
and there are other factors involved we
did hear from also Granite State
independent living and from New
Hampshire Audubon about their opposition
and generally we did not have support
for the bill so that is the reason for
my emotion of itl Mr chair thank you
thank you representative we're the maker
of the second wish to speak on a second
I have nothing to add
thank you does anyone else wish to speak
I guess not so um Can the clerk call the
roll on a motion to itl
thank you
and you're gonna be last right yeah okay
okay
on uh House Bill 141 motion itl uh
representative C
yes
representative gold
yes representative Horrigan
yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf
representative McHugh is
yes
yes okay
um representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
yes
representative wrong yes representative
Kelly
yes representative Simpson
yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes
representative Hoyt yes representative
LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes
representative Ryan yes and
representative harp yes
motion passes Ito on House Bill 141
thank you
I did mention earlier to some of the
people we'd like to have the briefs on
these motions in by Friday at noon time
if you could email them to myself and
chairman renzulu who was not able to be
with us today so that we can get them in
the house calendar that would be great
we have
motion to consent any objections
consent
House Bill 174 relative to the filing of
notice of intent to cut timber
I believe I have a motion from
representative Harvey bolia your motion
okay so thank you chair I make a motion
OTP for House Bill 174 with the
amendment but so will
OTP is the first amendment yeah so we
have a motion of OTP on 174 do I have a
second
seconded by representative McHugh do I
I uh would like to also make a motion to
which
everybody should have a copy
uh so we have a motion to approve the
amendment the amendment number oh
23-071h do I have a second on the motion
thank you
we have a motion on the amendment
seconded by representative McHugh would
you like to speak to your Amendment
representative
yes uh just briefly I emailed all
members uh this amendment so
um this comes after a lot of uh this
most recent Amendment comes after a lot
of discussion about um uh how best to
meet all the needs of bloggers and the
dra commissioner and also Town officials
and so consensus seems to be pointing uh
at adding the most recent Edition which
would be on line 31.
um
it just simply says
if uh provided that the assessing
officials have not communicated to the
owner a reason why conditions for
approval have not been met uh the owner
May commence The Cutting operation and
then I added after submitting a copy of
the intent and providing the data filing
to the commissioner of the revenue
Administration
so it gives an extra layer of protection
for the town officials and the timber
Cutters and that's the reason for that
thank you
thank you do you wish to speak to your
so after some consultation with the
other members and representative
aribulia
I agree with this amendment uh it uh it
does allow for adequate notification it
simplifies the process if the town fails
to respond the timber Cutters agree to
this amendment as well
electronic notification and the calendar
day provision uh simplifies the process
entirely and streamlines and allows the
timber cutters to cut when the weather
is most
most appropriate for their cutting
without without further delay
so support this emotion
thank you representative anyone else
which wishes to speak on the amendment
hearing none will take a vote on the
amendment
Amendment
um okay so representative harb
ORS I mean I'm sorry representative C
yes okay representative Gould yes
representative Horrigan yes the clerk
votes yes representative Healy yes
representative wolf
yes representative McHugh representative
Donnelly yes representative Don yes
representative Vale
yes representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes and representative harb
yes
from 20 to zero I'll recognize
representative Howard ebubolia for
do you mean to call the
role okay OT ah I see otpa
um okay
so make a make motion of OTP a
um
for house bill 174.
um as amended so do I have a second on
that second representative in the queue
second any discussion on the motion of
otpa
seeing none uh call the roll please
thank you
okay representative C yes uh
representative gold yes representative
four again yes click votes yes
representatively yes
representative wolf yes representing the
Q yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale yes representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes and representative
yes what's 20 to nothing
otpa any objection to consent
consent
next bill HB 205 relative to testing
private Wells do I have emotion from
representative McHugh
motion to find this bill and expedient
to legislate
representative wolf second set
if you wish to speak to your motion
representative McHugh
I do we have two bills on this
subject
and I believe we'd like to take up
the other Bill house bill 398.
uh
over this bill and find a
House Bill 398 as the as the bill that
we prefer to pass with a notification
requirement
um
over this bill
thank you do you wish to speak to your
second
Mr will representative wolf
no
any further discussion on the motion
representative uh Darby
thank you Mr chair
um so uh House Bill 205 and House Bill
398 are substantially different from one
another house bill 205 includes water
testing Provisions House Bill 398
includes
a disclosure Clause as well I think that
we should act on 205 and not find in
Expedia intellectually
because the water testing provision is
critical to the quality of water in New
Hampshire
thank you anyone else to speak on the
motion representative Iran thank you Mr
chairman
um I I agree with my colleague from
Nashua and want to point out to my
colleague from Merrimack that these are
very two different bills
um 398 only addresses notification
that's it where 205 requires water
testing for new wells and the reason
that is so critically important is we
have very inconsistent analysis
throughout the state as we heard in the
public hearing and I believe it was uh
Mr Grace from New Hampshire water well
associations that there's inconsistent
water tests between municipalities he
wants more standardization
there was an antidote about a person who
was happy they're well passed but it was
only tested for bacteria where someone
in another Community might find they
have arsenic lead chlorine green might
be measured so there's very inconsistent
standards throughout the state and this
gives very different expectations and
assurances to Granite Staters and I
believe they all deserve to have their
water tested with the same analysis the
same analytes so that they can be
prepared to install if necessary the
proper filtration or treatment systems
it's going to be far more expensive I
would expect and for them to discover
after they've been living in the house
that they have a contaminant that they
could have easily installed a treatment
system for during the construction
and it all depends on what that water
test is so I'm I'm very much opposed to
killing this bill I think we need the
standardization it was also supported by
Mr Brandon Kieran from the Des is
drinking Water Division
so I I do would implore my colleagues on
this committee to defeat the itl so that
another motion can be made
thank you thank you anyone else wishing
to speak on the motion to itl
representative representative would you
consider retaining this bill so that we
can work on it and defense I agree with
actually much of what you said about the
inconsistent standards and I do think we
need to work on it actually and I'd
almost prefer to retain it especially
for our specific community
and I wouldn't mind working on it and I
wish that we could actually take up the
other bill first
for that purpose but they just came in
this numerical order yeah would you want
to consider
retaining this bill
and so we could
fix it
representative wrong okay thank you Mr
chair actually Mr uh representative we
did actually did work on an amendment if
you remember the only concerns that were
brought up in the public hearing was
that pfas was included in the testing
requirement so the amendment removes all
pfas it's only included in the Des
notification in fact the bill becomes
almost a mirror image of House Bill 667
which passed the house and the Senate
back in 2020 but it died of covet death
it couldn't it couldn't get the final
vote before the deadline
so this this is this is already a bill
that's been debated and studied in both
the house and the Senate a few years ago
I don't think we would be able to
improve upon that by retaining it so
um perhaps after the amendment is shared
um you may realize that it does address
all the concerns that were brought up in
precisely why I was hoping we'd take up
the other bill
um you and I had spoken about that
I think in a hallway conversation
uh
um well we do have emotion on the floor
so
um as far as I mean Mr chair if you
don't mind me just making a remark about
um I think that's the bill to retain
yeah
I think we need to talk about the motion
to itl so
if there's nothing else on itl
okay
um for the motion of
there's a motion going around now and I
know we're in the middle of voting itl
on 205.
but representative McHugh had made a
good point is it possible
to
get what we want or do are we stuck
because of the order that this was
presented to us
I'm not going to take them
representative wolf I appreciate your
question but I'm not taking them out of
order I think we vote on the itl if it
doesn't pass then we'll entertain
another motion it appears to me that
representative McHugh will probably make
a motion to retain if that doesn't pass
so we're going to stay in this order
so we're calling the roll call on itl of
H Bill 205. share
okay thank you
representative C yes
representative Goulds yes
representative Corrigan yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
yes
representative McHugh
yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
no
representative wrong no
representative Kelly no
representative Simpson no
representative Baldwin no
representative Darby no representative
foyt no representative LaMontagne no
representative Lovett
no representative Ryan no I am
representative harp
yes
okay if I can count that's 10 10. so the
motion fails so a representative McHugh
did you have a second motion you'd like
a move that we retain House Bill 205
a motion to retain House Bill 205 do I
have a second
second seconded by representative Harvey
bolia do you wish to speak to your
motion
thank you Mr chairman
um yeah for the reason I was stating
before uh the bill does need a little
bit of work
and even with the amendment that I'm
actually just still reading
even with this amendment I still see
some language that's
far from objective that we actually
address in an amendment
that was sent out to the the chair and
the vice chair and the ranking member uh
in 398.
so I'd like to retain this bill to work
on that language
there's already some mandatory testing
on Wells and there's already uh Des
notification for anybody within 500 feet
and there's already
um widespread notification of pfas
contaminants throughout New Hampshire on
the Des website
so I think we should consider retaining
this bill
and I urge the committee to support a
motion to retain so we can further
consider the exact right language of
this bill
thank you
this is the second wish to speak
no thank you I think representative
representative Darby
thank you Mr chair
um so I would definitely uh recommend or
suggest we vote against retaining this
bill
um we we know that there is no Statewide
testing of uh of wells and we know as uh
as my colleague from Merrimack pointed
out that
um that Des supports this
um the uh the well drillers support this
the Realtors support the language that's
in this bill and that this had at this
the bill that this is based on as it was
mentioned 667 passed on consent in 2020
so I would definitely uh recommend to
suggest that this does not require
additional
um clarification in terms of the uh in
terms of the language and we can vote
against retaining this thank you
anyone else on the motion to retain
representative wrong yes I'm I'm also
against the motion to retain and I want
to uh
remind my colleagues that commissioner
Scott in his letter to us dated January
30th said HB 205 is very similar to HB
667 that passed the House of
Representatives in 2020 but was not
considered by the Senate due to covet
disrupting the regular legislative
process significant work in
collaboration between legislators
industry and public health
Representatives occurred on HB 667
during multiple legislative work
sessions while the bill was considered
in the house the primary difference in
HB 205 of 2023 versus HB 667 of 2020 is
that pfas has been added to the list of
contaminants that must be tested for a
newly constructed Wells
if we get to emotion with an amendment
you'll see that all that pfas has been
taken out in fact
um with this with this amendment if we
consider it will actually enable 205 to
revert back to HB 667 and as
commissioner Scott stated there's there
was so much work done on that I don't
see how a retain is going to make this
better that the amendment already does
so thank you I'm against the retained
motion
cue anyone else to speak on the motion
to retain for the first time
representative Vale
thank you Mr chair
I also speak in against the motion to
retain this bill
and I you know I just really think that
it's this is the time to get the
standardization
out there for people that the insurances
that people in New Hampshire need that
they're preparing and their their
supplying themselves with the correct
filtration for the contaminants that
they're facing
um is isn't is a it's not something that
can wait and what concerns me about
retention is that there has been quite a
bit of work done in this bill we have
much support for the work that was done
on House Bill 367 and I think we should
go ahead with the agreed-upon language
that um that came from House Bill 667
and and we should pass this Bill thank
you
anyone new on retention representative
Donnelly
um
Amendment and
take out arsenic
correct that we want to take arsenic out
of this bill
I don't have the amendment in front of
me
could you pass it up no this one still
has
we're not speaking on the amendment but
what is the amendment can someone tell
me the amendment number so we're all
looking at the right Amendment sure
through with arsenic
point of order
if we're not speaking about the
amendment we're not speaking about the
when you motion to retain did you want
to speak again representative McHugh
thank you Mr chairman
um if the if the bill takes out pfas I
mean don't don't we want to keep it to
get pfas in there I mean in that
I mean that's the that's the fundamental
concern at least for oh
sense
the last couple of years since this
since 66 cents 667 excuse me die to Cove
of death I mean pfas has become more and
more of a concern and I think we want
some discussion of pfas in the bill
I mean that's the point of retaining it
like we we agree on
90 of this we may not agree on the exact
language to be in stature what's in
statute and what's in rules
but let's let's get to a point I mean
this isn't a this isn't is not an
artificial retain so we can send it to
interim study or whatever
it's a it's truly an effort I mean this
is a bipartisan issue especially for our
town uh in Merrimack
we want to do something about pfas and
get something passed
and we've got Amendment options
on 398 in the numerical numerical order
so I'm I was a little surprised when you
uh representative Rowan when you first
mentioned that b fast came out because I
think that's kind of the central issue
here is is some standard or some testing
or some notification or some combination
of both
on pfas
so why
why pass a bill
without pfas in it
I'm it's maybe it's a bit of a
rhetorical question
thank you representative I'm going to
represent recognize representative
LaMontagne then representative Kelly yes
I
similar concerns about that but one of
the objections about including the pfas
compounds and the standardized testing
is that many people felt well it's not a
problem everywhere in the state
though it might be but that's why we
want to include the really strong
notifications about pfas and and the
transactions so that we don't require
everyone to do the much more expensive
testing for pfas but if they see this
warning then they say oh maybe I should
get it it's not um mandating it but we
wanted to keep the really strange strong
language about pfas in the notification
and then
um
another thing is that the pfast testing
is is a little bit fluid there's some
new problems with the testing
um there might be some contaminates in
treatment systems representative run
could speak more in detail about that
but this bill establishes
um standards for well testing without
requiring pfas across the board though
it could be added later as we learn more
about it but this bill keeps a strong
language about pfas in the notification
that
um
if you you mentioned
um that it might be they could go to the
Des website and see information about
pfas but most buyers aren't going to do
that if they're going to get the
notification with their real estate
documents that's where we need to have
an impact so that's representative Kelly
thank you Mr chair yeah I'd just like to
add that the bones of this bill caught
date back to 2019 study commission this
is what we got I think that it's
important to pass this it's been four
years already to pass this now get this
in in statute and then worry about
improving the bill with pfas
with a separate bill nothing's stopping
us from doing that with a separate bill
next year I think also the EPA is about
to release their
recommendations around pfas and it's
important to wait for that step but we
shouldn't hold up the rest of the radon
and uh and let in all Arsenic and all
that stuff from from that part uh so
so I'm going to recognize myself for a
comment I don't think we're all in
agreement with the language of uh 205
whether it's amended or not amended so I
would be voting in favor of a retaining
and knowing how we're likely to pass
whatever we're going to do on 398 that's
another reason colorly to support
retaining 205 so if no one else has a
question I'd like yes
thank you Mr chair I just run it real
quickly go back to representative McHugh
I do think that pfas has been very
important and come to our attention
especially in the last few years but I
know in other communities in the state
these um the other things that will be
tested for that are on this list have
been of concern across the state and
other places so I think when
stakeholders came together in the study
commission they really were also
interested in having standards across
the state for the other issues that are
in there
thanks
I'm going to ask for a call of the
question on
the motion to retain so can I ask the
on House Bill 205 motion retain
representative C
yes
representative Goulds
yes representative Horgan yes yes
representative Healy yes representative
wolf yes
representative McHugh yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale no representative
wrong
no representative Kelly no
representative Simpson no
representative Baldwin no representative
Darby no representative Hoyt no
representative Lamontagne no
representative Lovett no
representative Ryan no and
representative harp yes so I think we
that leaves us one motion a motion to
ought to pass who would like to make
I'd like to move on to pass
ought to pass move my representative
wrong representative Darby second
representative rung you wish to speak to
your motion about to pass thank you very
much I'd like to make a motion about an
amendment motion oh yeah okay
um make a second motion yes
I'd like to make a second motion to
amend
um House Bill 205 with Amendment
20230734h
and I'll second that
representative Darby moves to amend by
20230734h representative Darby wish to
speak on your Amendment motion yes thank
you Mr chairman so first first I'd like
to start
um by talking about the origins or about
the differences between this amendment
and the original House bill 205.
um the original House Bill 205 had two
additional statements in it one was it
had pfas testing and a section on PBS
testing and it had a um
yeah sorry it had pfas testing we heard
a lot of concerns about pfas testing
both in terms of cost and terms of
in terms of
the locations and the whether or not the
p5's testing was needed Statewide the
other change between this amendment and
the original 205 is that
um as as my colleague pointed out this
strikes out the the explicit arsenic
Clause
um from the from the notification
language
it turns out that that arsenic Clause
was also stricken in the bill that this
was based on which is as we've been
talking about 667 from 2020. the purp
the reason that that specific Clause is
stricken is because there's a much more
comprehensive statement about water
quality as a preface to the
notifications it's called contaminants
it starts on line 14 on page two it
indicates contaminants common in well
water what we heard is that different
areas of the state are impacted by
different
um different
not largely naturally occurring
contaminants whether they're radon
uranium Arsenic and
um and Des has very specific uh Des has
very
um very extensive information on the
website which is called out on here
about the New Hampshire well water test
for home buyers and how to even
um how to even check your results if you
if you go down I've spent a lot of time
on the New Hampshire Des website if you
go down that you'll see that the page
that they refer to talks about all of
the contaminants that are listed on in
section four of this bill however it
does not call out pfas pfas is um you
know is a is not a naturally occurring
contaminant and that's why we had to add
an explicit section into the
notification portion of
um of this document of this amendment
for pfas to make sure to to ensure as as
has been spoken to that home buyers are
are aware that they pfas may in fact in
fact infect their wall water the reason
reason some people have asked you may
have received an email about why radon
and lead is left but we've stricken
arsenic it's because if you read the um
the radon notification it calls out
radon in the air as the as the the first
uh as an explicit
um sort of source of radon exposure it's
also in water it mentions in water but
the first case it covers is an air
similarly with lead lead is first
described about as being as being a
concern with respect to lead paint it's
also in the water it can also be in
water but lead paint and so we have to
leave the lead because of lead paint we
have to leave the raid on because of
radon in the air the contaminants and
common common in well water cover the
arsenic
um and so this this
um the language that's in here has been
um has been uh
verbally approved by Des it's been
verbally approved by the um
by the Realtors and we also heard in
testimony that the well drillers
supported 667
and 205 without the pfas testing
requirement so this this bill basically
meets the um
meets the the is agreed upon by the vast
majority of
um of constituents that are impacted by
the the businesses that are impacted by
it in organizations and I I urge you to
pass vote Yes on this amendment thank
you
representative Kelly
yeah I would just like to point out
again that this mirrors the exact
language from House Bill 667 which
passed Edna unanimously in 2019 was the
was the
outcome of four work sessions and the
the two key differences between this
bill and that one are first that the the
pfas notification which is rather soft
language and second is the line 14 on
page two
um the notification it says uh
harmful contaminants are found have been
found in private Wells throughout New
Hampshire that language is softened from
the original bill which was something
that was pointed out by the realtors
association that the language originally
said most private Wells and that
language has been slightly softened
um to to deal with their concerns so I
would again urge all members to to vote
for this and pass this just like we did
in 2019
thank you I'm going to speak against the
motion to amend
um
very against the Striking of the
notification of arsenic in my part of
the state arsenic levels have been
rising and I think it's important that
the buyer be made specifically aware as
he does about lead paint and radon of
the Arsenic and although it's not before
us immediately I think to combine this
amendment with amendments that are
related to House Bill 398 I'm against I
think it needs work that's why I
supported the retention so I'm going to
vote against the motion to amend
anyone else wish to speak
representative Iran
yes I I just want to clarify a comment
that representative Darby made that
arsync was removed because it's
redundant with language that is captured
under the uh well water testing uh
information that's provided through Des
so the only things radon lead and pfas
that are added to that paragraph
following that paragraph are just items
that aren't discussed in that well water
so we could we could go on and on about
mentioning a lot of things besides
arsenic could be chloride could be
sodium could be E coli but the
notification is just the the first
paragraph which captures Arsenic and
other things and then three other things
that aren't delineated in that well
water testing information provided by
Des to get to representative use issue
before about why pfas was taken out in
the original bill it it's specific fine
for specific pfas which are currently
under regulation by nhdes they have
maximum
contaminant levels but we know in
Merrimack that Sanko Bain has been using
Gen X and that is something that perhaps
by the Fall when we get more guidance
from EPA when analytical methodology can
be more specific to each pfas that's
used
if this goes into statute it it would be
more expedient and more accurate to
amend it to keep current with current
the current situation of pfas but right
now even as this bill is not amended
does not account for Gen X and
um so I I'm holding in support of the
amendment I think Granite Staters
deserve to have consistent well water
testing I think it's it's a shame that
depending on you where you live is going
to determine the quality of water that's
tested coming from your well so I I hope
everyone can you know consider voting in
support of the amendment thank you
on the amendment anyone else
representative wolf
yes Mr chairman if I can ask
so you would prefer
to see
this bill without the Arsenic with the
Arsenic notification in there even
though
the bill
says that it has to be arsenic has to be
tested in line 15.
so there's not a specific notification
on arsenic but it's in line 15 on the
things that have to be tested for
so would we not be improving the
situation by passing that even though
you don't have that extra layer of
notification
representative wolf my answer that would
be no so I think you need to have the
Arsenic because
um representative Darby's mixed two
bills basically together the
notification well I'm looking at the
amendment that was put forth and it
talks about the notification of
contaminants and Wells under 477 4A so
that deletes arsenic so that's not about
testing it's part of this bill as
amended or the amendment is when you
sell your house you give notifications
to the buyers he's taken the arsenic out
so that's why I'm not in favor of the
amendment
yes ma'am
thank you Mr chair
um can I ask a clarify clarifying
question that might help so
and I haven't been thoroughly exploring
the Des website so if I were to go to
the Des website and look up New
Hampshire well water test for home
buyers would it say something on the
website already explicitly about
does anyone yeah do
thanks I don't know if we have any
experts in the field to answer that that
the
but I just point out that the amendment
section one is about well testing with
new well constructions not about the
sale of your house that's the second
Mr chair members of the committee my
name is Ted deers I'm the assistant
director of The Water Division at the
New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services uh newham Des has
come out in favor of these bills with
various different suggestions and I
think that the uh the amendment that
representative Darby has put put forth
largely consolidates uh the language of
398 and 205 into one particular bill
um indeed if you go to and I would just
I I would I'll answer the answer I'll
answer it directly your question
directly and then I will just expand one
bit on that in terms of how Des will
react to this particular bill being
passed
so the answer is absolutely yes if you
go to the New Hampshire well test and if
you go to the to be well informed uh
parts of our website you will find
really good information written for
homeowners about the constituents that
are listed uh in the amendment from
lines uh first page lines 15 through 29.
each of those and to to take
Representatives harbes comment directly
because it's very it's something I'm
sensitive to as well
is that in your particular area of the
state arsenic is a problem I happen to
be putting a well in somewhere where
radon is most likely a problem
um I just talked with somebody for whom
hardness is a problem in their
neighborhood
and I have also talked recently with
some folks who have had really bad
problems with manganese
in their particular neighborhood and
this is the complicating factor in all
of this is that um it gets confusing for
everyone uh to understand the
differences between those various
analytes that's why I think that this uh
the conversation that occurred both in
667 the conversation around 398 and the
conversation around 208 205 gravitated
back to this idea of let's have a common
frame of reference and that's this be
well informed area what will Des do with
this if this bill is passed I can tell
you that one of the things that we will
do is that we're going to do a lot of
work within our website and also the
Outreach that we do to through our well
drillers and through the well drilling
board through the water well board sorry
to do Outreach on this to ensure that
the messaging that goes out about how
people get to this website how they
understand the information that's in
there how they actually can get those
resource is from other sources as well
from their own well drillers will be
consistent it will be consistent with
the language that's in this bill it'll
be consistently labeled it'll be easier
to find and it'll be elevated within our
website to make sure that as people come
into this situation that they can
understand what's going on when they get
a relatively you know I think for most
humans a relatively complicated set of
test results it's going to be very
important for them to to do that so I
just want to note that those those are
kind of how we will react
um in order to make sure that I think
representative harb's concern is
addressed that people clearly understand
what arsenic or chloride or manganese or
radon means for them in their particular
domicile
anyone have any questions for Mr deers
representative Harvey bolio
thank you Mr deers
um I had a conversation with somebody
from Rules
and I noticed on this amendment that
there's an awful lot of specific
information about
directing people to a website a specific
web page
Etc
my concern with this is that a lot of
this verbiage in here
really should say you know rule the New
Hampshire Des should be uh setting the
the language as far as the form because
in 10 years
you may have re you know redone your
website
there could be a lot of there's going to
be changes in this whole section over
time so I that's one of my concerns with
this is that it is
a lot of this stuff should be sort of
hashed out in rules all the details and
directing people here and there and
telling people how to to access things
thank you that's I just wondered if you
had any comment on that thanks
uh thank you representative I think it's
a great question this is a common
um
back and forth uh Evan flow that occurs
I think uh here uh in this committee as
well as others related to the role of
Statute versus rule
um clearly uh when we have something in
rule it's it is very it is something in
statute it means that's what we're gonna
do
very clearly within rule there's
abilities to waive there's abilities to
get to do other things there's it but
like you said there's some more
flexibility
The Way We have dealt with this in the
past because this has occurred in the
past I mean we've had websites for
you know nion 30 years here that
um there's there's often ways that we
can redirect there can be redirects
especially if it's in statute we can
create redirects and that that's a
technology issue that's relatively
straightforward to address
um and and frankly my guess is is that
over the next 10 years or or whatever
um most likely this issue will come back
to you all and uh I think you already
heard from representative wrong that as
the world of pfas becomes more
um
comprehensive and understood that there
may be additional analytes that might be
added to this at some point in the
future
so I I think that this is something
that's going to be addressed by this
committee over time and we would
certainly work with the committee to
make sure that however we do this
whether it's in rule or statute and I
would just say standing sitting here
today we're agnostic
but that we would you know we'll we'll
make it work for however you all want to
representative McHugh question for Mr
deers thank you Mr chairman thank Mr
deers for taking my question
um how does the department plan to
enforce
this since I see there's a violation and
how do you define the unhealthy levels
wait make sure I have the right number
20 degree
I'm not sh sure I'm looking okay
so yeah though this is really this is
really a good question in terms of
things that go into
um and I'm sorry it's hard to see around
the speaker here
um thank you for the question and in
terms of what would actually Des would
enforce Des won't enforce Provisions in
a a real estate contract
that that is not something that Des has
the ability to enforce so we don't have
that kind of ability that's something
that happens between realtor client
closing mortgage all of the different
you know
mechanisms by which people buy and sell
property in the state so that is not
something that Des enforces is part of
real estate documentation we don't have
ability to do that in terms of the
testing we have a water well board the
water well board would regulate what
well drillers are doing and it would be
largely based on you know when people
would bring a complaint that they didn't
get you know notified or something like
that and that would go back to the water
well board there's a way to deal with
all of that
in terms of the actual language on 23
you know this is this is part of the
whole setting of mcls this is the whole
part of you know setting of agqs's it's
this ongoing conversation I think it's
representative wrong described about
what levels are going to be harmful and
that's going to change we know that
that's going to change as new science
happens as more more compounds are
studied
um as the industry stays you know a step
ahead of all of this trying to make
safer compounds and creating new ones
that we don't know much about so this is
all going to you know be changing over
time which is why that language I think
is is relatively I think it's okay
language in that it it it it does uh
point to you can have unhealthy levels
and those will be defined
differently over time uh so does that
get at the the question that you had I'm
follow up thank you thank you for the
follow-up no not at all so if I
understand it correctly uh it's a moving
Target I think I heard you say or it's a
it's going to change and it's going to
be different over time those unhealthy
levels so you'll have to adjust how you
how what those unhealthy levels are
referred to in line 23.
and testing the wells
you have a way to enforce testing the
wells but with all this additional
testing
sounds like we need a fiscal analysis
and we need in this budget year we need
to appropriate some funds to help you
Monitor and enforce
all this additional testing I don't see
a fiscal note attached to either the
original bill or the amendment so should
we ask for a fiscal note or can you guys
perform a fiscal analysis for us
well I I can tell you the amendment
thank you for asking the question I
don't know that a fiscal note is
necessary because this data does not
come to Des
is data that goes to the buyer
from the seller or or however that's
working in the real estate transaction
we don't get this data we will not be
enforcing on this data
so to the extent that someone has a
problem they will be able to identify
that and then work that out through the
transaction to be able to sure that that
their water is going to be okay so there
really is not a role except within
responding to complaints which is
something that we already do so I'm not
sure that there's a need for an
additional physical note there's
mechanisms to deal with all of those
things already and and if there were a
fiscal note we would be looking at
whether or not
there are going to be more complaints
and how that would cost but that it's
going to come out to be indeterminable
because we have no idea so I I
respectfully I I'm not sure that that
would necessarily change the financial
picture
anyone new
no okay okay Mr dears thank you very
much for your testimony absolutely thank
Mr dot representative Darby
thank you Mr chair
I want to make sure that we're on the
same page about how this bill
um relates to the original Bill House
Bill 205. both bills had two sections
the first section in both bills covered
well testing the second section that's
number two that starts on line six of
page two had notification requires
you'll notice that these these refer to
very different rsas that's because one
has to do with testing of new wells
that's the entire first section testing
of new wells only
the second section which is which are
existing tests affordable tests that can
be done by a number of by the state
laboratory and a number of
commercial Laboratories across the state
the second section talks about a
notification required as you might
require as people might recall the
Realtors following the original hearing
on this sent out what the notifications
look like these are included in the
um in the uh
um
profits a p s statement and there's a
list of the notifications this is
basically going to replace the
notifications that are
um that are in the ex that are in the
existing pns's that they send out today
that's why this doesn't have a fiscal
note on with respect to section two
representative Darby are you speaking
only about your Amendment yes yes
absolutely only about my Amendment I'm
talking about section two line six
um of the amendment on page two
this is only with respect to the
notification section in the pns of real
estate transactions there is no testing
requirement or any cost associated with
it thank you
we're going to make a comment then I'm
going to call this question
um I heard Mr deers mentioned that be
well informed had all of these things on
the web page and notifications already
so if I really followed that line of
thinking we don't need any new statutes
just tell people go look at the web page
secondly I am concerned about the part
two beginning on line six again because
that relates to the same bill that is
398 I have been advised that there may
be a motion on 398 to retain so I don't
know why we're not retaining this bill
either and again I would vote against
the amendment but I appreciate it being
brought forth so I'm going to ask the
clerk to call on the amendment this is a
motion to amend you're either in favor
or against can you call the role Madam
Clerk
um on the Amendments for 205 uh
representative C no
uh representative Colts
no
representative Horgan no
clerk votes no representative Healy no
representative wolf no
representative McHugh no representative
Donnelly no representative done no
representative Vale yes representative
wrong yes representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Point yes representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett
yes representative Ryan yes and
representative harp
no okay so we got another 10 10. so now
we go back to the simple motion of ought
to pass made by representative rung
seconded by representative Darby
I believe we have to take a vote on that
when anyone like to would you like to
discuss your motion simply to pass
not to pass as I said before I am
disappointed the amendment failed it
doesn't preclude a floor amendment to
coming in what's critically important is
to give Granite Staters
consistent water testing when they are
getting a new well we cannot tolerate
having one town test for bacteria and
another one testing for arsenic and lead
I mean everyone deserves to have the
same analytes tested when they're
constructing a new well that is the
heart of 205 that's what we need to get
through
even if there's analysis for pfas
it's not it's not going to take away
um the ability for someone drilling a
new well to get information on the
quality of that water that could impact
their health it could also influence
things that they do in their home
treatment systems they decide to install
so I do urge my colleagues to vote ought
to pass on this and let's do something
good for the people of the state thank
you
um
I will agree that this is very important
I think there's a lot of challenging and
complexity in this bill that needs
rewarding so I'm I'm hoping that we can
come together to understand how we can
really pull this together and you know
Bill 398. it's I'm just I keep looking
at this and go the complexity doesn't
need to be as bad and it for the
constituents for the people who drilling
Wells for the people buying houses for
them to have all this complexity to
continue to try to sort through
makes it difficult for them to
understand what they need to do and yes
I do agree that we should have
consistency and and what the wells could
be tested absolutely should be agree but
let's do what's right for our
constituents and really help make this
clear and I'm in technology as far as I
know websites will change we may not
have websites in 10 years from now who
knows what we're going to have you know
trying to build in technology into any
Bill bad to do because technology will
always change so I would love for us to
really work to make this simple for our
constituents make it simple for the well
drillers make it simple for Des let's
look at simplifying and helping people
instead of complexity thank you thank
you
representative McHugh
thank you Mr chairman I will be voting
no against this ought to pass but
representative wrong I I wouldn't
preclude the possibility of a floor
Amendment and I hope we can actually get
398 passed so we at least get half a low
for the notification
um
but there were some issues with the
amendment unfortunately this still made
it imperfect so I couldn't support the
amendment
I hope we can sit down between now and
the time this comes to the floor and
consider what was make it make a better
amendment I agree with representative
Donnelly that we should do something to
make it simpler correct some of this
language I mean I still think there's a
path forward I thought retention was the
right way to go to give us the time you
you mentioned that there were some
things happening in the fall so the
timing might have been actually right
for retention but anyhow it's it's
conceivable we can still get there I
think 398 may get us part of the way
there
unfortunately the way this bill is
written uh in its original form and the
way the amendment was I think we should
probably keep arsenic in there that was
one of the reasons I couldn't support
that Amendment
um I've seen arsenic in my own water
actually
um anyhow so I can't support it as it is
couldn't support that that particular
Amendment but I think we could probably
get there I think we're pretty agreement
I'd like to hear what some of the other
uh representatives from Merrimack the
one on this committee and the other
members from Merrimack who actually
aren't
uh in in this particular room
thank you
anybody new
um I would like to see this bill passed
testing component it's just the
notification so if someone gets a
notification have your water tested
once again they're going to have it
tested and there are no standards they
say oh I might have arsenic I might have
something I'm going to have my water
tested
but there's 205 is the only thing that's
going to guarantee that every new well
is testing for arsenic among other
things I also have arsenic
in my well and I'm really grateful that
it was tested for that
but I'm lucky I live in Dover where they
have higher standards so we're trying to
pass something to make sure every new
well is tested the notification in 398
is not going to do that and I think we
need to take action on it I don't find
this bill overly complicated to
understand
um
kind of wrong thank you Mr chair
it appears that and correct me if I'm
wrong but that the opposition to the
amendment was on the removal of the
language of ours from about arsenic from
the notification
would you be willing Mr chair to
consider recessing the executive session
so that an amendment could be made we
still have the optic pass motion open so
if we can bring another amendment where
we put that arsenic language back in if
we don't have time to exec it now
perhaps we can do it after the public
hearing this afternoon
but I think it is within your power that
you can recess the executive session
until amendment can because I I can I
you know representative Darby we can
I appreciate your question but I'm not
going to postpone this I think if you
can work with representative McHugh
before it hits the floor there's a lot
of work that needs to be done on this
and I thought that's why we were perhaps
going to have a work session that was
canceled then we tried to put forward by
Miss by representative McHugh a
retention so would have time to work on
it and then all the people involved and
other people could be brought back in so
I'm not going to hold off a vote on this
I'm sorry okay I'm going to call that's
okay
but you still have time as
representative McHugh said to try to
work something out before it hits the
floor I'll take one more question
because I don't think this is going
anywhere representative Darby
thank you Mr chair I will be brief I
know I've spoken a lot
I just want to um
stress a point that representative
LaMontagne said which with respect to
new wells oftentimes new wells are
replacement Wells and they go into a
different part of the aquifer and while
you may have had your world tested when
it was a dug well now that it's an
Artesian well you have a completely
different contaminants this um the
testing portion would cover that well
the other portion that I wanted to say
is that the bones of this bill was based
on the Seacoast Commission on long-term
goals and requirements for drinking
water which was a bipartisan commission
with our own
one of the members is on this committee
from uh from Bedford and so I I think
that there was bipartisan consensus and
I would urge OTP on 205. thank you
thank you I'm going to ask the question
be called and let the clerk call the
roll call it is with no motion with no
amendments to pass ought to pass as
written
uh could you call the role Madam Clerk
on Hillsville 205 uh representative C no
representative gold no representative
Horgan no clerk votes no representative
Healy no
representative wealth no representative
McHugh no representative Donnelly
no representative Dunn no representative
Vale yes
representative wrong yes
representative Kelly
yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes and representative no
it's 10 10.
so we've gone through the gamut of all
of the motions and they've all come out
10 10 so my understanding it will go to
the floor
um with no recommendation I believe last
representative McHugh who made the
motion itl to write a memo on that and
representative wrong you made the motion
ought to pass so can you write the memo
on that as I mentioned memos should be
submitted to myself and the chair who
regrettably couldn't be here today by
noontime Friday
and I'd like to take just about a one
minute break
um before we go into our last bill
398.
foreign
so what do they have to do
um
thinking
can I ask the members to take their
seats
I think we're all back I call them
meeting back to order thank you for your
patience uh we're on House Bill 398.
I understand representative wrong has a
motion to make on 398. actually
representative Darby does
representative Darby I'd like to make a
motion to retain House Bill 398. we have
a motion to retain made by
representative Darby to win a second
I'll second it we have a second by
representative rung would you wish to
speak to your motion Mr Darby
yes thank you Mr chair
um we we just heard that the language in
um the notification language
um
requires some rework in addition during
the original testimony there was concern
about the disclosure language that's in
house bill 398. I think it's best to
retain this so that we can work on this
language together thank you
thank you anyone else to speak on the
motion to retain 398 representative
McHugh and then representative Vale
thank you Mr chairman I would have to
agree there is some
work that we could do to rework the
notification language it's important we
get it right so consumers and residents
of New Hampshire are are completely well
informed on where to get the test how to
get the test what levels to look for and
all the resources available to them and
to get the input from DS on these
different standards so we have some a
little bit of time to do that so I would
definitely support the motion retainer
I'd ask that my fellow community members
to do the same thank you representative
Vale
Mr chair I Echo
exactly what representative McHugh said
those are my comments
thank you any other comments on the
motion to retain
seeing none Alaska clerk to call the
rule
thank you very much representative C yes
representative gold
yes representative Horgan yes clerk
votes yes representative feely yes
representative wolf yes representative
McHugh yes representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
yes representative wrong yes
representative Kelly yes
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes
and representative harp yes that's 20.
so we'll retain
398 and be aware I understand some of
our members will be working on a floor
Amendment for 205 so watch your emails
uh for that before we actually see it on
the floor I'm sure both uh
the Republicans and the Democrats will
probably have a caucus on the floor
Amendment if they can get it out quick
enough
um I'm gonna adjourn this portion of
today's hearing we will reconvene in
about 20 minutes at reps Hall uh for the
speed bill on Lake Winnipesaukee and I
thank you all that came in your patience
foreign
now
can I ask you all those to please take a
seat members of the committee please
take your seat your name tags are
I'm going to call the hearing on hb448
relative to Lake Winnipesaukee speed
limits to order thank you all for being
here would you all please rise and join
thank you you may be seated
my name is Bob harb I am the acting
chair of resources Recreation and
development today let me introduce a few
things in the call to order I am going
to ask that people limit their speeches
and their presentations to two minutes
we have quite a few of you to speak so
if you could hold your presentations to
two minutes we have passed out any
written testimony that was submitted if
you have other testimony when you
approach the mic let us know I will
announce who's speaking next and who's
on Deck it does not matter which
microphone you go to to my left and my
right in the center aisles there you're
going to see a microphone so you can
approach the microphone give your name
your address tell us whether you're for
or against the bill and then proceed to
give your testimony if you are asked and
you take any questions please remain at
the microphone until
you're answered all the questions if you
I'd also like to announce that at the
end of today's hearing we're going to be
immediately executing this bill and I'll
repeat that again for those present at
the end of the hearing and testimony we
will then proceed to exacting voting on
the bill we're going to do that today so
there won't be a second session we're
going to do it all this afternoon I
appreciate your understanding on that
so in our usual protocol for those of
you visiting us and in the house welcome
to the house we always say that welcome
to the house this is our first time
resources being in the house to conduct
a hearing so it's a quite an event for
us I'm going to call forward the sponsor
of the bill representative bordes of
course he's supporting the bill so he's
going to speak in favor of the bill he's
the prime sponsor representative bordes
good afternoon Mr chair and members of
the committee I stand before you to
introduce House Bill 448 relative to
speed limit on Lake Winnipesaukee last
year I came before the transportation
committee to introduce a similar bill
with the intent of removing the speed
limit on the entire Lake
um after conducting some research and
speaking to several people it was
determined that we come up with a
compromise Bill uh in regards to the
speed limit on Lake Winnipesaukee this
bill
um which simply increased the speed
limit from 45 miles an hour to 65 miles
an hour in an area known as the broads
the broads is the biggest wide open body
of water on Lake Winnipesaukee
um you're going to see hear some arguing
that people you know a kayak there it's
a safety issue
um number one
as far as kayaking in the broads go
during the weekday in my personal
opinion I believe it's fine safe okay
join the weekends when that lake is
twisting and turning and very rough I
personally would be scared to get out
there on a kayak or a canoe or
any other vessel like that you're going
through here an argument that about
Shoreline
um erosion now a simple fact and I
didn't bring it this time I had a 30
page print out at the last hearing
showing that the faster a vessel goes
the less weight it throws now a wake
boat will throw that's traveling at 15
20 miles an hour is going to throw a big
wide week
with a high performance mode or some
people like to call it a cigarette boat
as soon as that boat gets up on plane
the week dissipates and there's barely
any weight behind the vessel this
argument has been going on for years in
regards to that and it is a scientific
fact that the faster a motorboat goes
the less wake it will throw
um
I mean this bill in my view I have
people on my side of this bill that are
angry with me and obviously the other
side's angry I felt we should come up
with a compromise that would benefit
everyone
um our biggest Revenue stream in The
Lakes Region
in my view is Lake Winnipesaukee and the
Lakes Region as a whole I could go
across to Lake winnerswam and I can race
a boat around at 120 miles an hour no
issues there's no speed limit
there's no regulations but speed limit
in New Hampshire we have What's called
the 150 foot rule what that means is any
vessel needs to be 150 feet away from
another vessel where one of the few
states that does have this rule I feel
we should be enforcing that role rather
than a speed ordinance or a speed limit
on the lake
the area known as the broads is just
wide open I'm literally on my boat every
single day of the week in the summer I
even go out in the rain sometimes
and I could go from Meredith over the
Wolfeboro and count on two hands the
amount of vessels I see
now the weekdays I mean the weekends I
will say is a completely different
argument
we have a lot of people from out of
state that come out uh boat
registrations are up throughout the
state but that does not mean people are
using their vessels uh last year I saw a
drastic decrease in the amount of boats
on the water even on the weekend due to
um I mean it's just common sense we have
much smaller bodies of water that do not
have a speed limit
and on our biggest open body of water in
the state we are regulating and
restricting certain vessels there's some
people that even say they don't want any
boats on Lake Winnipesaukee I have three
people say that to me today
um
that's nonsense we need the revenue we
need the tourism I used to be able to go
to bars and restaurants and and places
on the lake on a Wednesday and not be
able to find the dock space ever since
the speed limit was enacted I've seen
weekday boat usage drastically decline
um hotels that used to be fully booked
are no longer fully booked during the
weekdays
it's an economy issue as well it's in
the Lakes Region and I really think we
should have some common sense and allow
quote unquote high performance vessels
to participate on our Lake and have
equal access to our Lake the other issue
is in regards to equal access if you own
a motor vessel you have to pay your
registration fee
those uses a kayaks canoes paddle boards
do not pay a registration fee for access
to the lake
that's not equal access to me
we also have
in regards to 150 foot rule I constantly
I I'm gonna bite my tongue off on this
constantly see people breaking this role
I think Marine Patrol should spend more
time enforcing that role than the noise
ordinance or the speed limit on the lake
again I just look for you guys to make
the right decision the Lakes Region
economy is very important to me and many
people and I don't think we should be
chasing away people that would like to
come to the area and spend their money I
appreciate your time and thank you very
much
representative will you accept questions
yes I will does anyone have a question
of the representative
thank you for taking my question
um I'm a phys I was a physics teacher
can you tell me which what where the
rule is because I really would like to
see it is it part of Bernard Louise
principle I'm not really sure uh which
rule are you the one on the faster goes
unless you said the higher the boat the
faster the boat goes the less the less I
can email the committee on the actual
information you did I can thank you very
much because as a physics teacher I'm
really interested yeah oh no it's it's
yeah it's very detailed it's like 30
pages long now just tell me which rule
it is I'll look it up I'll have to look
it up on my phone thank you I appreciate
that
any other questions for the
representative
it would help me members of the
committee if you raise your hand if you
want to ask questions I don't see any
hands raised so thank you representative
for your testimony thank you uh next up
is representative McDonald and on Deck
is Robert Lemuel
if I said it right
thank you Mr chairman and a good
afternoon everyone colleagues my name is
John McDonald and I represent the folks
of the town of wolfbone the community of
Tuftonboro and we have about probably 8
000 people year round in those two
communities and we probably grew up to
about 40 000 during the summer months
I'm a lifelong resident of Wolfgang and
I'd say I probably got several thousand
hours of voting experience on liquid
besaki I retired from a 30-year career
on law enforcement and during my career
I worked for the New Hampshire Marine
Patrol
and now we're supporting education
officer full-time for the entire State
and it probably spoke to uh several
thousand people about voting safety
issues and providing boating education
I'm also a graduate of the national uh
Coast Guard safe boating school and I'm
also a licensed commercial boat operator
up to 70 feet and 700 horsepower
for the past several years I've been a
captain on the Winnipesaukee ball which
does daily cruises on the quinnipesaukee
and also Charters during the evening
I appreciate my colleague and my friends
comments uh concerning the uh the
economy I'm not seeing that in my
community uh we're busy a lot of boats a
lot of people uh motels and hotels are
sold out uh we just spent about 650 000
on the docks in town to remodel those
and we also provide
assistance in docking boats so we're
spending a lot of money to keep
everything going
uh
over the years I've seen a lot of
changes and the past 10 years since it's
last been in effect
I don't know what what he's trying to
change the only thing that's increased
the league the lake isn't any any bigger
and it's not any smaller it's about the
same size
the same considerations that the members
back in I guess it was 2010 when they
passed this fee limit still exist we
still have a lot of boats we have more
people that aren't just doing water
skiing and driving around but the using
as it as a mode of transportation either
going from an Ireland property to shore
to your groceries or to a restaurant to
the big thing about boats and it asks
you folks to consider this is uh
we would strip speed on snowmobiles oh
hivs and what do boats not have that
those type of vehicles have
brakes a boat doesn't have any brakes
all you can do is put it in neutral and
again we still have safety concerns just
10 years ago
I like to think we hear a lot about
cigarette boats and all the money that
people have spent on cigarette boats I
look at as if I go buy a Corvette and a
Porsche that can do 200 miles an hour I
still have to go 60 or 65 miles per hour
on the interstate a boat shouldn't be
any different
if you want to go out do 100 miles an
hour 70 miles an hour they can slide
down and go on the ocean where they will
support that all right I'd ask you folks
to uh
not pass this bill I.T outlet and let
the state consider consider uh the
reference in promoting boating safety to
keep the legs
especially liquid masaki uh safe for
everyone not just as high speed boats
thank you
if you take questions representative yes
does anyone have a question of the
representative
seeing none thank you thank you Mr
chairman next up Mr lamoreau who's in
support of the bill and on Deck
Lieutenant Dennis Wade of the Department
of Safety
Mr lamoreau
I have to press that
thank you very much for hearing me
um I do have some documents that I don't
know
how to get them to somebody or is
somebody going to get them from me
um I appreciate you listening for a
minute I basically wanted to get into
talking about hydrodynamics and
aerodynamics of boats that it seems like
nobody pays attention to
aerodynamics and hydrodynamics are
heavily involved with the way boats run
when you put a 45 mile an hour speed
limit on the lake that 45 is pretty slow
to pack enough air underneath those
boats to get the boats to ride properly
all the new technology coming out in
these new boats is going to have Aero
and hydrodynamics involved in them look
at the hulls when you look at the hulls
they have
uh you know different steps in them well
those are all about the air and the
Hydraulics and and exactly what what
this gentleman had said about the waves
he he's correct you know the waves isn't
the problem it's the ice I'm on the lake
destroys my front yard every time pushes
all the Rocks pushes all the boldest
I haven't seen any boat waves ever make
any difference on the shore but I
certainly see the ice
so someone wants to tell you that
go take a look at what the ice did come
to my yard
um as far as
you know the the personal effect that
was on me is you know I get a I get a
fish boat my fish boat is a tunnel boat
that tunnel boat doesn't even begin to
work at 45. so he wanted me to go 45 but
I can't get the boat up out of the water
enough to get up to clear the way so I
just beat the crap out of myself driving
around the lake
I mean it it's pretty unfair
um the other thing is that you know
we're going to lose out on a lot of
technology in these boats these boats
are going to have more more air and more
aerodynamics and hydrodynamics built
into them and we're going to miss out on
those boats beautiful technology boats
that we're not going to be able to get
on the lake because your speed limit's
too slow
now you know I've raised tighter planes
all my life and you go around in these
other states and countries and they
laugh at us because we got a speed limit
on one of masaki they laugh at us it's
kind of embarrassing
but anyway now
um the other thing that I wanted to
mention to change subjects is um
you know the law the law should be for
the majority not cater to a small
minority who really have no knowledge of
the effect on everyone
I mean they think they have the
knowledge of the effect on everybody but
they don't I don't I don't know how they
get away with it and then they they sit
in front of their computer and they use
their computer and make themselves look
almighty God powerful
and feel you full of crap and I don't
think that's right I think it's totally
wrong
for for us to listen to a small little
group
you know you need to listen to the big
group the big taxpayer
if you put this on a ballot it'll
probably get wiped out and end up with
no speed limit because there's more
people that are probably in favor of no
speed limit and no speed limit now I'm
approaching my two minutes I'm sure uh
the last thing that that I want to make
mention is you know the lake is very
dangerous and very unforgiving I mean
you can die easily in that Lake all
right and I've done many many many small
boat canoe and kayak paddle rescues
trips out there you know getting people
with these small little boats
they they always seem to be in trouble
and there's a lot of deaths there but
you know we're not stopping them
and there's a lot of deaths in these
small little boats and if you could
bring it to a conclusion we don't and we
don't stop them I I just doesn't make
any sense to me so I hope that everybody
here has common sense for all and not
for a small minority
all right thank you for listening to me
I appreciate it do you take questions
yes anyone have a question for the
Mr lamaro
go ahead in the front
representative I can't the way you're
raising your hand
I guess not all right I guess no
questions I don't see any hands way up
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you very much before Lieutenant
Wade speaks uh on Deck Harry Vogel Harry
Mr chairman uh members committee um good
afternoon I'm Lieutenant Dennis Wade
Commander New Hampshire State Police
Marine Patrol
I'm here representing the department of
safety the division of State Police and
to testify against uh house bill 448.
Lake Winnipesaukee is one of 30 lakes in
New Hampshire where there is a per se
speed law
the speed limit on most of these other
30 Lakes is 10 miles an hour with just a
few being above that
Winnipesaukee currently has a speed
limit of 45 miles an hour from one half
hour before Sunrise to one half hour
after Sunset basically daytime
and 30 miles an hour at night time these
speed limits are not absolute they are
allowed only where no other Hazard
exists where a lower speed is uh
required
these hazards include were not limited
to boat traffic weather waves sunglare
swimmers
and water debris
driving a boat at 65 miles an hour can
be dangerous a boat moving at 45 miles
an hour is traveling at 66 feet per
second where a boat traveling is 65
miles an hour it's traveling at 95 feet
per second almost 30 feet difference
that 30 feet can determine the time
needed for a driver to avoid a crash
the average perception reaction time for
a person is approximately 1.5 seconds
this is perception reaction time for a
driver who is actively paying attention
in that 1.5 seconds a boat traveling at
45 miles an hour will travel at 99 uh
we'll travel 99 feet
65 miles an hour that boat will travel
142 feet
again this is reaction time then the
driver's actions has to have to take
place to actually avoid whatever Hazard
exists
unlike Motor Vehicles boats do not have
brakes requiring additional stopping
time and distance on the water
an operator can only throttle back and
maybe even put the boat into into
reverse still this will not stop a boat
quickly and the steerage of a boat does
not operate the same when it's in
neutral
Lake Winnipesaukee is used for many
different recreational activities
water skiing swimming canoeing kayaking
fishing
sailing motorboating and many more
there needs to be a balance by the use
of all these recreationalists to include
motorboats
although there's an area defined in this
law where the 65 mile an hour speed
limit would be allowed that would be
hard to distinguish there are no defined
edges in the water like you have on the
roads there's no sidewalks there's no
yellow and white lines no travel lanes
and no no traffic control devices
add in that not everyone on the lake
knows the lake has been there before
will not be familiar with the boundaries
discerned by this law this can make for
a very dangerous mix
having the area defined throughout
through written law
would not be the same as having a
clearly defined area that a voter can
understand
when driving a road the road is defined
you know when you're turning onto or off
of a road you have curbs and
intersections you also have speed limit
signs traffic control devices caution
signs yield signs this will not be the
case in Lake Winnipesaukee should this
law pass
how will the motor know when they're in
the 65 mile an hour Zone not necessarily
because they plan on going fast but so
they can be more cautious of other
voters that might
there were kids in other novice boaters
who vote on this Lake are they going to
know where where they are and what
hazards to look for in order to sign
this to sign this area so all users knew
that this was a 65 mile per hour Zone it
would take an unknown number of buoys to
be placed at an unknown cost
buoys and unexpected places that can
also pose a hazard
we do not want to create additional
hazards especially in an area does not
necessarily have environmental
obstructions this would also take away
from the beauty of the lake
two other items to consider
boats do not have seat belts nothing to
keep a passenger in a boat should the
driver have to throttle back at 65 miles
an hour to neutral or should it get hit
by another boat or run aground there are
no airbags no roof nothing for
protecting the passenger from being
ejected should a dangerous situation
occur
think of the interstate we do not allow
bicycles and pedestrians on the
interstate because of the speed limit
having a boat going 65 miles an hour
near someone canoeing kayaking or
sailing can be a recipe for disaster
although these motor boats have just as
much right to the lake again as anyone
else there needs to be a balance
in summary the department of safety is
not recommended passage of this
legislation it creates an enhanced
concern for safety of all users in this
area will cause confusion among voters
especially those who are unfamiliar with
the lake
and as presented does not allow for
proper enforcement on the Zone based on
the description of the area
thank you lieutenant does anyone have
any questions for the lieutenant
representative Darby
will you take questions Lieutenant
absolutely
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
in online testimony we heard a number of
people
um comment on the the decrease in Marine
Patrol on Lakewood Massacre
Winnipesaukee
myself having a uh a camp on a small
Lake in Southwest New Hampshire have
also noticed a significant decrease in
Marine Patrol I was wondering if you
felt if you if the department of safety
feels that the
coverage Marine Patrol Patrol patrol
coverage is adequate and if not if you
could comment on why there's why there's
a decrease in the Marine patrol coverage
thank you
um no it's not adequate
um
reasoning it's probably like every every
other law enforcement agency in in the
state in the country everybody's having
a hard time filling these positions
um unlike many other agencies we have
mostly a seasonal or part-time staff we
only have uh nine full-time staff
throughout the year as far as law
enforcement
uh the other the rest of them are
seasonal staff some who actually work
throughout the year but many who do just
what you expect coming around April May
maybe June work throughout the summer
um and then go back to their other jobs
many are retired many are college kids
um so we are definitely below below what
we would like to see for our staffing
and it's it's certainly an issue with
enforcement uh being out there being
being present
and just letting people know we're out
there so it's a very difficult thing to
do and it's it's we're always weighing
where we need to be and and how many of
us should be there
any other questions for the lieutenant
I don't see any thank you lieutenant for
your testimony
before I ask Mr Vogel to come up I have
about 23 cards all opposed to this bill
of run out of cards for anyone in favor
and we normally alternate is there
anyone else to speak in favor that
hasn't entered a pink card
I'll ask one more time anybody else in
favor that hasn't filled out a pink card
hearing none I'll ask Mr Vogel to come
good afternoon Mr chairman and committee
members for the record my name is Harry
Vogel I am the senior biologist and
executive director of elune preservation
committee I also sit on the
Environmental Policy Committee of New
Hampshire Audubon and I'm representing
that organization as well this afternoon
learn preservation Committee in New
Hampshire Audubon opposed House Bill 448
for two reasons the first reason is
concerns about our loon population
loons are a state-threatened species in
New Hampshire lpc's intensive management
has more than tripled the population of
lewins in this state but loons face some
big challenges including the challenge
of fast-moving boats and personal
watercraft
collisions with boats and personal
watercraft account for 13.8 percent of
known causes of adult loon deaths on
Winnipesaukee that is eight times the
percentage of other lakes in the state
mortalities from both collisions also
affect loon nesting success because once
you lose a member of a loon pair it can
be years before elune finds a new mate
and returns to productivity
boat collisions also affect the survival
of loon chicks young loons are small and
dark they are not easily seen by boaters
and they are too buoyant to dive away
from a fast-moving boat
those fast-moving boats are very common
on Lake Winnipesaukee and loons on
Winnipesaukee have seen larger declines
in their population and their breeding
success compared to lewins and other
areas of the state
the loom population on Winnipesaukee is
decline from an historical level of 40
to 50 pairs to an average of just 28
pairs
collisions with boats and personal
watercraft are one of the largest known
causes of living chick mortality on
Winnipesaukee fewer than 7 out of 10
loon chicks that are hatched on Winnie
survive to fledging that's 10 below the
Statewide average
loons on Winnipesaukee have fledged
fewer than 0.4 chicks per pair per year
on the lake that is 19 below the
Statewide average and that breeding
success is not enough to maintain a
viable population of loons on the lake
the second reason that loon preservation
Committee in New Hampshire Audubon
opposed this bill is concerns about our
biologists and our volunteers on the
lake
so this summer the loom preservation
committee will have 12 biologists on New
Hampshire's Lakes working for the public
good and to protect the socially and
economically important Wildlife species
some of those biologists will be on Lake
Winnipesaukee and they will spend more
than 400 hours on the lake in a small
Boston Whaler our boats have a top speed
of about 35 miles an hour but they will
be able to cover the entire Lake very
well
over the years as we have seen more and
faster boats on Winnipesaukee I have had
increasing concerns about the safety of
our biologists and our volunteers on the
lake and speed limits have helped to
alleviate some of those concerns
and the final point that I would like to
make is that loons are the tip of the
iceberg and so the same things that are
affecting loons are affecting mergansers
and mallards and otters and other
wildlife
loons and our other Lake Wildlife bring
residents and visitors to our state they
contribute to our economy and to the
spirit that makes our Lakes special to
New Hampshire's residents and visitors
it would be a shame to lose the very
qualities that have attracted both loons
and people to our Lakes so the Loon
preservation committee and New Hampshire
Audubon support limiting excessive speed
on our lakes and so we oppose House Bill
448 that is the end of my testimony I
would be happy to take any questions we
have any questions for Mr Vogel
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
up next Mr strodl on Deck Mr Ratcliffe
Mr strodel
can you turn on the mic you have to
press the button so it goes red there
you go
good afternoon my name is Bob strodel I
am a longtime New Hampshire resident I'm
a second generation camp director
and I've been in charge of camp
brookwoods and Camp Deer Run for 30
years we also operate a camp called
Moose River Outpost in Maine
let me tell you how happy I am to be
running two camps in New Hampshire and
not two camps in Maine it is hard to run
a camp in Maine so thank you for all the
good stuff you're doing help support New
Hampshire camps
we are opposed this bill
for the basic reasons we're concerned
about safety there are approximately 14
camps on Lake matasaki there's only
about three McDonald's around the lake
and I'm not sure how many Dollar
Generals but there's a lot of camps
around the lake we've got up to a
thousand campers that are Lake alone and
we represent along with the other camps
approximately a third of a billion
dollars as far as input
the reason I oppose this is considered
safety that's the bottom line I don't
care about the hydrodynamics I care
about the safety of the kids
look over at this wall right over here
first
now look at this wall over here
in less than a second a boat traveling
at 65 miles an hour will transfers that
distance
and a camper cannot get out of the way
if you can't present a canoe a kayak or
a sailboat so we'd appreciate it if you
you accept questions
anybody have any questions for Mr
strodel
seeing none thank you for your testimony
up next is Mr Radcliffe and on Deck Kate
Lemay
Mr Radcliffe good afternoon my name is
John Ratcliffe I graduated from Maine
Maritime Academy in 1983. I've been a
professional Mariner for 40 years I hold
an unlimited tonnage Master license upon
oceans which is the highest license the
Coast Guard issues
addition to that I have a master ocean
towing with 1600 ton Master ocean
fishing 3000 ton master high speed
vessel an oem modu among other
certifications I've lived in New
Hampshire and voted here for over 30
years
over the 30 years on the big lake I've
watched the situation deteriorate as the
go fast boats take whatever piece of the
water they wanted pushing the kayakers
canoers and anyone on smaller slower
Boats off the water out of fear
I've watched commentary and local social
media people being swamped by boaters
ignoring wake zones right of way and the
response from any was the laughing emoji
and you should get a bigger boat
indeed one couple I know in their late
70s having their lunch at anchor within
150 feet of a shoreline
were swamped so badly they had five
thousand dollars damages to their boat
they were knocked around the boat and
fortunately while they were not injured
they easily could have been
there's no doubt we've lost
consideration for others on this Lake
in the course of my career I worked
aboard a high-speed vessel at Westpac
Express and service to the Marine Corps
in the mid-2000s on that vessel which
had a maximum speed of approximately 40
knots on open ocean not 65 Plus in
enclosed Waters full of skiers kayakers
and yes there are kayakers in the broads
Crossing between the iron the swimmers
also we had to maintain a bridge watch
on that vessel as follows two men in
control chairs at all times with an arms
reaching the throttles one licensed
engineer sitting in a command chair
above and behind us whose job was to act
as a third Lookout
on this vessel we had ectus arpa AIS and
other modern safety features
on that vessel if I wish to get up and
relieve myself I had to have the chief
engineer in the chair behind me and the
other command chair occupied just to be
able to stand up
there's no distractions on such a vessel
no music no visitors and obviously no
alcohol
let's contrast this with a go fast vote
on the lake with kids on board or beers
in hand or sometimes both
towels and toys flying about the boat at
all speed all of which are distractions
to the operator no formal training no
collision avoidance equipment the boat's
operating in constricted Waters with
small buoys kayaks wakeboarders and the
occasional swimmer as I mentioned
earlier I've been on this Lake for over
30 years
in that 30 years I've been swamped
several times
I've had many close calls each time it
was about operating at excess of speed
in the two cases where I called the
Marine Patrol and the operator was
stopped alcohol wasn't a factor speed
and stupidity were
the lake is becoming a wild west of
boating with those who have the biggest
fastest boats climbing the right of way
having the money to buy a bigger faster
boat has no correlation to experience or
nautical skills the lake just isn't big
enough or open enough for boats to
operate at least be as requested there's
no time savings and attempts to claim
that this is is just an excuse if you do
the math the speed difference between
the current speed limit and about doing
80 miles an hour traversing the broads
ends up to a difference of four minutes
that's from the southern temperature
rattlesnake to Sandy Island
it's all about the fun Factor and that
person's fund shouldn't outweigh the
safety of others if you don't have four
minutes to spare then maybe you should
thank you does anyone have any questions
for Mr Radcliffe
Miss Lemay on Deck Mr Hutchins
hello hi my name is Kate Lemay um I just
want to first thank you all for your
service to our communities and just the
people that have spoken I think the the
care and thoughtfulness they put into
their points is really important
um so I am the senior executive director
at the YMCA camps of greater Boston and
they own Sandy Island which is at the
corner of the broads in this uh in the
map where this is affected my statement
is that we're opposed to the increased
speed limit obviously because of camper
safety but what I would also say just in
being here is that
if this restriction happens and the
decision is that this is the one spot
where boats can go 65 miles an hour
it is going to concentrate that speed
into this section of the lake and our
camp services about a thousand people a
summer but many of them are families
with young kids and one of the great
aspects of our property in this facility
is that
once you pass a swim test you're able to
sail around the island paddle board
kayak it's it's safety is one of the key
aspects of this Camp so
um I would say that I'm just really
grateful that the speed limit is
currently 45 because I think that
people
as you increase the speed limit their
decisions of what they can do to go
faster is just going to increase so that
isn't just 65 65 could meet 85 65 could
mean 75 and concentrating it in the
broads has a significant I mean it's
right it touches half the property of
this island so I'm just grateful that
the speed limit's 45 for now thanks
thank you for your testimony any
questions
next up Mr Hutch
Hodgkins and on on Deck Miss Jay Newton
on Deck
good afternoon I'm Warren Hutchins of
Guilford New Hampshire and I am against
the bill requesting the uitla I am a
multi-generational New Hampshire native
and I live full-time on Lake
Winnipesaukee
I have been an active boat of my entire
life
I am a combat veteran of Vietnam having
been involved in serious safety
situations that happen very quickly like
you I have devoted my time and efforts
for the people of New Hampshire
I have served the 34 communities of the
Lakes Region Planning Commission for
over a dozen years on its executive
committee serving as chair for multiple
years
this commission supported the speed
limits of 45 30 on the big lake
during these years I also serve the
people of Laconia as chair of the
planning board
the Laconia city council also supported
the speed limits on the lake to promote
safety and economic development
there are very few regulations
concerning boating operations on our New
Hampshire lakes in comparison to other
modes of recreation and transportation
voting speed limits are just common
sense for safety Recreation for all
types of drivers
the Lakes region is a driver for our
state's economy in large part due to
Lake Winnipesaukee
please itl this very selfish request of
a very few presented for their personal
Thrills at the safety risk of all other
boaters
the current law of 4530 was a negotiated
law and at that time there was much
discussion concerning the broads this is
a major part of the lake and it is like
a major intersection that so many boats
of different sizes need to cross to get
to Major ports or residential areas on
the lake for simple enjoyment
please honor the work of your
predecessors in the House and Senate and
do not modify this simple to understand
safety regulation
this is the 14th hearing
on this simple Common Sense regulation
enough is enough
the prime sponsor of this bill presented
the same concept last year at the same
time
the transportation committee voted to
itl this bill
here they are again before another
committee
last year the brides were presented and
the lake were presented as large as the
Manchester airport by the prime sponsor
this really supports the need for
recreation boating speed limits for all
types of boats
the airport is very controlled as you
are all well aware
nothing moves without a pilot or ground
air controllers there are very few
marked runs they are very well marked
runways very limited access to the field
I could go on and on the brides on Lake
Winnipesaukee have none of these and
boating operators range from the very
young to the very old very experienced
to the very new
the lake is for New Hampshire residents
and recreational guests not a racetrack
for a few
the ocean is near and wide open let them
race there thank you very much
any questions for the speaker
seeing none thank you very much for your
testimony
Mr hello I'm Jay Newton I and I'm here
representing myself and Mel Ingles who
could not be here
we both are Guilford residents I and
we're both in opposition to HB 448
we both live on the lake he lives there
all all year long and I live there in
the summer on Welch Island which is
adjacent to this the area they want to
increase the speed on
and I just have to diverge in my so
first of all don't be worried about my
large packet here I'm only covering the
first page the next four pages are
something about a safe system approach
and the last five are about Mel's
accident he has he is on the lake every
day when there isn't any ice he kayaks
from his home out into the broads
through the islands and back every day
and so he has a lot of familiarity with
that and he had the unfortunate
experience in September of 2020 of being
run over by a boat that was racing
another boat
so he has definite information about how
speed affects people's decisions how
people make mistakes and it can cause
big problems on the lake so very quickly
safety is Paramount in a recreation area
the broads are like a park my wife and I
look out and Mel sees this every day
it's just people either floating in
their boats sunbathing with kids all
around swimming pulling kids on a tube
paddle boarders windsurfers canoers
Sailors Fisher people fishing it's it's
just a nice place to hang out it's like
a park in the middle of a busy City
because the rest of the lake with three
with 30 000 temporary licenses in
addition to all the all the standard
permanent licenses that that we have is
just crazy just a two mile trip I take
from my dock on Welch Island to get to
the mainland is can be harrowing you
don't know when people are going to turn
and come for come out you know come at
you you look once at one minute
everything looks good the next minute
there are three boats coming and there's
a kayak you have to avoid an assailable
at this coming over this way that you
have to avoid so basically it's a it's a
place a little more room where people
can enjoy themselves and feel safe offer
so the other part of this is about
safety and about how speed affects
safety and I bring up the U.S Department
of Transportation safe system approach
it's something that's been working its
way around the world and our DOT is
finally adopting it and it basically has
a few tenants and the most important of
which is serious death and serious
injury and death are unacceptable we
used to I think accept some deaths we
knew that if we raise the speed limit it
would increase the number of deaths on
the road it was a known fact and yet we
thought well for Commerce we've got to
get people to their jobs we got to get
goods and services delivered and so
forth they're saying no no more so they
have a multi-pronged approach which is
detailed in the next five pages but
basically
um the one one of the major tenants is
that humans make mistakes we have
wonderfully designed highways we have
really safe cars now and yet in the last
seven years we've gone from 30 000
deaths caused by cars in in the United
States to 40 000. that's a thirty
percent increase
and so a big part of that is speed and
they say that speed kills and I have
these little uh speed limit signs here
so at 23 miles per hour if you get hit
by a car you have 90 chance of not dying
at 58 not even the 65 that they're
advocating in this bill you have a 10
chance of surviving
and the um and I would say this
translates pretty well to the water but
it's even worse on the water if you
consider the dangers of drowning if you
get hit by a by a hit and run car and
you're lying on the roadside there's
probably a chance that somebody's going
to come along and see you and maybe be
able to save you if you're sinking in
the water
somebody might not even know that you
even were hit and if even if they know
you're there they might be looking for
you and they might not see you on the
bottom
so and then the other part is being
injured by the boats for pillars which
is what happened to Mel he was severely
cut on his legs by the boat's propellers
it had two Motors each motor has a
propeller with four blades spinning at
thousands of revolutions per minute and
they cause him Serious injury that had
him laid out for several months he's now
back with a healthy lifestyle he does
have some parts of his body that don't
work the same as they used to we're
happy he survived so the last thing is a
quote or next to last is when you bring
it to a conclusion Mr yeah the last
thing the quote from the Insurance
Institute for Highway Safety
and if anybody knows how many people are
being injured and died it's the
insurance people so speed is unforgiving
of human error making collisions both
more likely
to occur in more deadly
so in some Nation I like to say a vote
to oppose HB 448 is a vote for safety
and to preserve the recreation area
known as the broads on the
quinnipesaukee thank you thank you any
questions for Mr Newton
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you up next Miss Adams and on Deck
Barbara
fioravanti
Miss Adams this is on this is on
hello my name is Abby Adams and I'm from
I live in Wolfeboro New Hampshire and I
oppose hb448
I want to call attention to the 2021 U.S
Coast Guard recreational voting
statistics it lists the fall top five
causes of accidents as operator in
attention operator and experience
improper Lookout Machinery failure and
excessive speed
alcohol actually comes in at six and yes
while boating while intoxicated has been
a persistent problem on Lake
Winnipesaukee
but a boat that is speeding along at 65
miles an hour with an impaired driver is
far more likely to cause accidents and
death than one who is obeying the speed
limit
a family boater trying to avoid a
collision with an oncoming speeding boat
has a better chance of avoiding an
accident if the boat is traveling at 45
miles per hour or less
and now bass fishing fishing boats jet
skis and even family boats have the
capacity for going 50 60 80 even 100
miles per hour
you have heard examples of accidents
which have occurred on Winnipesaukee
and I'm enclosing one testimony from
Captain Levy from the Marine Patrol
as part of my testimony that involved a
swimmer
struck by a boat going over 65 miles an
hour
another
outlined in an email to the committee
occurred in 2020 and involved a 32-foot
speed boat which hit a kayaker at 35
miles per hour
said boat driver never even saw the
kayaker and you have heard that the
victim continues to suffer permanent
permanent and ongoing injuries
if the speedboat had been going 65 miles
an hour this accident would undoubtedly
have been fatal
so please keep in mind that the number
of people obtaining their boat license
in New Hampshire has increased from 6500
in 2019 to over 30 000 in 2020.
that's a 500 percent increase in new and
inexperienced voters on our Lakes
New Hampshire boat registrations have
increased almost 15 percent since 2013.
increasing speed even if quote just in
the broads is unsafe given the sharp
increase in boat registrations and the
significant
understaffing of the New Hampshire
Department of Safety
the broads is the Hub of the lake where
people must pass to get from one port to
another
Sailors Anglers family boaters use the
broads
some family boaters just pull up anchor
and drift With the Wind from north to
south in the broads
and finally as a member of the Wolfeboro
Waters committee and chair of the
Wolfeboro Waters Communications
subcommittee I work closely with the
Lake Winnipesaukee Association
you should be aware that both of these
organizations have opposed hb448
we urge you to vote itl thank you
thank you any questions from Miss Adams
seeing none thank you for your testimony
next up Barbara fioravanti on Deck I
don't know if she wants to speak if
she's here it says she doesn't need any
time Melanie Ratcliffe
Melanie are you here she's gone
she says no time so we'll put her card
aside on Deck after Barbara is Alan
posnack
Miss fioravanti
thank you
ladies and gentlemen thank you for the
opportunity to speak my name is Barbara
theoravanti I'm a full-time resident of
toughton borough and owner of a
Lakefront home on Lake Winnipesaukee
I am also a boater both power paddle and
sale and I'm also a seaplane pilot
I am opposed to this bill HB 448.
the proposal for increase in the speed
limit on Winnipesaukee from 45 miles an
hour to 65 miles an hour
Was Defeated last year for good reason
the conditions have not changed
the proposed restricted area of the
increased speed limit known as the
broads
in this bill is defined as the entire
central part of the lake
this means that all other craft
including slower sailboats pontoon boats
fishing boats and paddlecraft wishing to
travel from one town or Bay to another
must pass through an area of traffic
traveling at automobile highway speeds
picture a bicycle crossing a mile and a
half wide I-93
on a busy summer day the traffic on the
broads is heavy and traveling in many
directions
typical wave action on the broads can
hide a small boat until dangerously
close
besides the danger the majority of users
of the lake would find their enjoyment
curtailed for the pleasure of the few
for those who wish to engage in
high-speed racing on the lake
special permits can be issued for
sanctioned races with very lenient
letting everybody come over the two
minutes and now that we're on the second
half of everyone to speak against if you
can keep your remarks to the two minutes
that would be appreciated especially if
you have handouts which I will give the
members time to read before we exec
thank you you mean starting with the
next speaker
I'd like to point out that I drove down
here at 60 miles an hour in a car that
can probably go 120. that's just the way
that's the way the world works
um I'd like to speak to the proposed
boundaries and also to enforceability of
this act in the handout you have if
could I ask you to look at the second
page which has a chart of the lake on it
and you can see in that chart that the
sponsors have carved out a race course
on the best part of our Lake and broadly
speaking those boundaries are carelessly
drawn and they're dangerous and it looks
clean on paper but there are no yellow
lines on the lake they'll be hard to
enforce if not impossible impossible and
hard for visiting boaters to observe
if you look at the chart and start at
the top left the the boundary actually
crosses the middle of Sandy Island it
almost touches tuft and brow neck and
across his wolf burrow neck
this invites boaters to skirt the shore
and the legal distance of 150 feet is
way too close to me traveling at 65
miles an hour
if you move down that Northern boundary
of the line it passes Parker Island and
there's a fairly narrow channel between
Parker Island and the shore and that is
cut in half by two black buoys and the
remaining channel is definitely too
narrow for travel at that speed
if you go away to the lower right corner
of your picture near buoy 78 the
high-speed area encompasses moose Island
Ship Island a bunch of rocks and shallow
area and six navigational buoys that's
probably not what you would expect in a
high-speed Zone
the further the bill says that the
course should pass outside of
Rattlesnake Island and you'll see in the
chart I question that which way is
outside
we may think we know but I believe it's
ambiguous it depends on on your
reference point it'll certainly be
ambiguous to a visitor
the
is that for me
that might be a good hint
the next page shows what's informally
called the upper broads and that is a
wide open space it's not within this
boundary but I find it very hard to
imagine that um voters who are enjoying
these high speeds will stop in the
boundaries they'll they'll Zoom all the
way up through the upper broads
and the last thing I want to say is what
what about 60 miles 65 miles an hour
last year the bill was for unlimited
speeds and they've kind of softened it
this year to 65. and to me that's a joke
maybe even an insult because who the
heck can tell tell the difference uh
Marine Patrol or any one of us whether
somebody's going 65 or 80 or even 100 so
in my view this bill is in Practical
dangerous unenforceable
and you all know what to do thank you
questions uh for the speaker yes Mr
McHugh representative McKee thank you
thank you for taking my question yes sir
is it Mr posnack yes sir would you
believe that from the hundreds of emails
in written testimony we got in
opposition of this bill
yours with the nautical charts was my
favorite
oh good
good reading thank you for pointing out
that some of the references went
straight through
a land mass so I enjoyed reading this
the other night when I got it well
hopefully these voters will choose not
to travel across the land mass but the
suggestion is that they're supposed to
drive very close to it when I got the
chart it was speaking my language so
thank you for sending that you're very
welcome thank you no further questions
thank you for your testimony up next Mr
Hennessy on Deck Mr Keeler
okay my name is my name is Brian
Hennessey and um
last week you all received documentation
of a serious serious accident on
Winnipesaukee in 2020 dealing how a
speed boat going 35 miles an hour never
even saw a kayaker the victim's life is
forever changed but I want to quickly
discuss two other reasons why this bill
should be voted Ito number one our local
economy
prior to the passage of the speed limit
Winnipesaukee had suffered from a
reputation as being a cowboy Wild West
destination several fatal and high
profile accidents involving high-powered
speed boats had contributed to this
reputation and this is why over 300
businesses signed in to support the
speed limit law we worked very hard over
10 years ago to adopt speed limits on
the lake and contest and can a test they
have made a remarkable remarkable
difference on the improved atmosphere of
tranquility and safety for all who
recreate there
a recent study conducted by Dartmouth
College and commissioned by
the Lake Winnipesaukee Association
showed that the lake generates over 17
billion dollars for the region and state
Taurus Anglers primary and secondary
homeowners are attracted to the lake for
its special beautiful
Recreation they feel safer boating as do
we with the current speed limits why
polish the speed limits for a select few
at the expense of the majority
we have many associations and businesses
that support our current speed limit
Lakes Region conservation trust New
Hampshire Lakes Association Lake Winnie
association Lake Winnie Sailing
Association Wolfeboro Waters Town
committee loon preservation committee
Sandy Island Camp several other camps
the list goes on and six marinas now why
would a marina
be against HB 448 they cater to family
voters and that's where they're making
their money
finally I want to point out that the
public supports our present speed limit
on May 5th 2010 the New Hampshire house
voted 268 to 79 on a roll call vote in
favor of the bill
in 2011 a Magellan poll was completed
showing 70 percent of those surveyed in
favor of the 45-30 law and 69 against 55
in the broads
on May 18 2011 the Full House of
Representatives voted to uphold the
speed limit
276 years to 75 Nays 45 not voting only
three out of the 20 reps from towns
bordering the lake voted against Art
and of course last year another bill
which would have increased the speed
limit on Winnipesaukee was voted down by
the transportation committee by a 17-3
margin I urge you to vote itl thank you
any questions
don't see any questions thank you for
your testimony
up Mr Keeler on Deck Mr Joseph
Doug committee my name is Jeff Keeler
thank you for the opportunity to speak
on the lifelong resident of New
Hampshire and I've been on Lake
Winnipesaukee since the early 60s I own
property on bear Island and I can tell
you on the weekends up there in the
afternoon we don't go to the you are in
the lake unless it's an emergency it is
such a zoo out there other boats going
every different direction and as
testified by other people before in
detention on the lake if you're
traveling at 65 miles an hour in the
space of 10 seconds you cover more than
four football fields I could bore you
with all the details and the safety
issues but the truth of the matter is
this is a bill that's about the wants of
a few versus the needs of all and that
the needs to be safe as I believe that
the committee is going to make the
decision based on common sense and
intelligence I'll leave it to you to do
your job and thank you thank you any
questions
you need to press the button so it
lights up there you go thank you good
afternoon my name is Douglas Joseph I'm
an orthopedic surgeon I've been in this
state for 55 years on this Lake
in practice for 40 years
I'm acting in opposition to House Bill
448. my family votes through the broads
regularly
when we boat to Wolfeboro tufenborough
Alton Bay or down to Center Harbor for
dinner or shopping
thousands of other Islanders do the same
as a physician involved with trauma care
my whole career
I can attest to the dangerous high-speed
injuries on our Lake on our state's
highways injuries to boating accidents
are no different except that they may
also involve
drowning high-speed boaters causing
injury and even death to slower speed
Sailors water skiers tubers paddlers and
swimmers are like cars striking
motorcyclists bicyclists and pedestrians
I've seen these critical injuries and
treated their grave problems and
counseled their grieving families
due to these horrified horrifying
accidents fortunately we have not seen
these high-speed accidents on Lake
Winnipesaukee for many years because of
the 45-30 miles per hour law
it's been working fine since 2009.
the lake has been safer and more
pleasurable over the last 14 years
my family's boating back and forth from
our Island Camp to the mainland has
become much more comfortable with less
anxiety
than it was before the law each time we
cross the channel before these speed
limits if we felt we were voting for our
lives
that fast boats will come out of nowhere
roaring through the channel and
elsewhere where we voted on the Lake
Boating wasn't fun it was incredibly
stressful
please do not take us back to those
times
vote against HP 448 and keep the 45-30
miles per hour law
as it is with no changes keep us safe
thank you
thank you any questions for the witness
up next Mr gurka I hope I pronounced it
g-i-u-c-a
as a Lakes region in a businessman and
voter I believe an increase in maximum
allowed boat speed could negatively
impact the businesses
boat safety and family life
last year the same house bill was passed
it was voted down and I question why
it's back
are there more important issues for
Representatives
in refiling bills they lost in previous
year
local businesses around this Lake
benefit from the current speed
conditions
because boaters and families feel safe
voting
going from town to Town shopping
frequenting restaurants ice cream shops
and stores
I see the boat traffic every year I live
in Wolfeboro
I visit their Town docks I go to
Meredith I go to Alton they also go to
the Weirs
to boats from town to town generally
means Crossing through the broads
the largest open section of the lake
but this is also where the high-speeding
boats will be
if the speed increase is allowed this
could dramatically impact Boater's
safety
for boaters crossing the lake
and crossing the broads this would be
like trying to cross a highway
likewise this could change the volume of
family boaters using the lake and
frequenting the businesses
I have been a realtor in The Lakes
Region for eight years
speaking with Lakefront owners and
boaters
and not once has anyone ever questioned
I am a boater and I know from experience
what it's like
years ago being in Maine in boating in
an area of high-speed boats
it wasn't fun
and for those who Sail
at Lake Winnipesaukee the broads is the
place to be
it's wide open however putting
high-speed boats and sailboats in the
broads at the same time is a very
dangerous mix
I have a question for you folks raising
your hands how many have been in a boat
okay very good very good well let me
tell you it's not like driving a car at
30 miles an hour there's no top
generally and you're right near the
water which would be technically the
pavement of the car
it is very fast
30 is fast my kids and they're in their
20s and 30s they think it's fast when
we're out and Michael so just also keep
that in mind and thank you for your
consideration thank you any questions I
don't see any questions thank you for
your testimony
Rocky and strongly oppose House Bill 448
like thousands of other Islanders my
family has to use boating as
transportation to and from our Island
Cottage we use our boats to pick up
guests and family to shop for groceries
to eat out at restaurants to carry
garbage or recyclables and to do a host
of other errands often through the
broads
what have we learned
what have I learned along with many
others over the last 14 years of about
high-speed boating and the 45-30 voting
speed limits law
first the American Red Cross and the U.S
Coast Guard have taught us about odor
fatigue from an operator's strained
visibility due to Sun reflecting on
Waters bouncing around on turbulent
waves motor vibration and noise adding
reaction time and reducing a boat
operator's ability to avoid an accident
motor fatigue can triple the effects of
alcohol
the average New England boat operators
tie behind the wheel is less than 35
hours per year so he or she may be rusty
oats don't have breaks or turn signals
and passengers usually don't wear life
jackets boat traffic goes in all
directions and is unpredictable
as a result many boaters are unprepared
for the unexpected and poor decisions
can quickly lead to tragic boating
accidents
secondly we have learned from
enforcement authorities at lakes around
the U.S where there are voting speed
limits that 95 percent of Voters abide
by speed limits just by having the law
on the books which is what we've
experienced over the last 14 years the
14 the 45-30 speed limits are
self-enforcing
they say that the speed limits based
regulation program is essential to
maintaining the recreational values of a
lake
as one enforcement person said speed is
an issue speed limits improve Reaction
Time cutting down on accidents and
injury boats have not changed in 40
years other than to increase power they
lack any safety equipment like that's
required in cars airbags padded dashes
Etc so boaters have no protection
for every fatality there are 20 injury
accidents and most are head injuries
that can result in drowning
speed and recklessness are the most
important factors
thirdly New Hampshire visitor brochures
South Lakes Region with descriptions
such as long Blissful sunny days spent
on the water days when swimming and boat
rides are savored and everything moves
at a slow summer simmer
here you can breathe a bit deeper Savor
each moment more fully and focus on the
important things in life and relax the
family vacation that calls up those
great memories from your childhood
let's preserve this safe family-friendly
Lake enjoyment please vote against House
Bill 448 and any changes to the
reasonable and effective 45-30 law thank
you
up next Nancy Watson on Deck Mark Watson
Nancy go ahead good afternoon
thank you for your time today my name is
Nancy Watson and I'm from Wilson Road
neaton
well my 93 year old father likes to
remind me that I'm no spring chicken
and he may be right about that because
this summer will mark my 36th year on
Rattlesnake Island facing the broads on
Lake Winnipesaukee like many people are
here today this is also the third time
in the last 14 years that I've traveled
to Concord to support boat speed limits
on the lake and I'm doing this because I
know they work before the limits were
enacted the boat traffic especially in
the vicinity of the broads was chaotic
on busy weekends large power boats
frequently raced to each other or
traveled in Pats at high speeds often
weaving around other smaller boats and
slower boats going in either direction
as well as crisscrossing the lake and
our camp has from the dock up to the
cottage about 60 steps so you have a
really good vantage point of looking
down on the lake and in looking down on
the lake it was intimidating just to
watch all this and it was even more
intimidating to be down traveling in it
since the Ackman of the beats the boat
speed limits more families now drift
more fishermen fish and more kayakers
and paddle boarders venture out into
this part of the lake the lake is
especially the broads is inviting for
all to enjoy and the gentleman who
actually testified earlier had a good
analogy of having this area be like a
park I mean you increase the boat speed
limits you're going to drive all the
people out of this area
and I don't see where creating a
free-for-all drag strip benefits the
majority especially in an area that is
the Hub of the lake and experiences a
high volume of use
don't burden rain Patrol with any more
responsibility
and individuals who operate these high
performance boats in the past when I've
listened to testimony justify their
desire for the speed by saying their
experienced boat handlers I don't
dispute that and they probably are
but you know everyone makes mistakes
we're all human
and please itl hb448 and don't give
speed the opportunity to create a crisis
and one more thing my father he taught
me how to drive a car
and he always used to remind me the
faster you go the faster you got to
think and I believe that also carries
over into voting
and dear old dad was right I hate to
admit thank you for your time
any questions seeing none thank you for
your testimony
up next Mark Watson on Deck Ken Robbins
Mark good afternoon I'm going to read a
letter from a marina owner on the lake
his name is uh Bob Conrad dear committee
members I am Bob comrade owner of North
North Water Marine formerly thurston's
Marina in Weir's Beach while I became a
marina owner in 2021 I had been a
property owner on Lake Winnipesaukee
since 2000 and a boater on Lake minnisac
Winnipesaukee since
1995. so I've experienced a lake with
and without speed limits it's clear to
me that Lake Winnipesaukee is a better
place with speed limits in all areas I
oppose HB 448
as a boater I do not want to return to
the days of being intimidated and
endangered by high-speed boats anywhere
on the lake
I personally had multiple dangerous
encounters with high-speed boats failing
to yield the right away
creating
anxiety for everyone in my party
as a marina owner on Lake Winnipesaukee
our business depends on families feeling
comfortable and safe boating in all
areas of the lake
families often multi-generational are
attracted to the lake which drives the
local economy through real estate
businesses on and off the water removing
the lake speed limit or increasing it is
a serious risk to that attraction for
families and the local economy
so as a resident voter and business
owner I oppose
hb448 and ask you to oppose it as well
best regards Bob Conrad
and I also personally I have a cottage
on the lake for over 35 years and I've
seen the lake before and after speed
limits and it is really impressive what
the speed limits have done to the safety
on the lake thank you
any questions seeing none thank you for
your testimony up next Mr Robbins
on Deck Miss bozelli
thank you very much for your time good
afternoon my name is Ken Robbins I'm
here both on behalf of camp tabian in
Alton Bay which is a century-old
summer camp where I am the executive
director but also on behalf of the New
Hampshire Camp Directors Association
which represents the approximately 180
residential and day youth recreation
camps in the state many of those are on
Lake Winnipesaukee most of my points
have been better articulated by those
who have come before me in opposition to
HB 448 I'll simply re-emphasize that our
opposition stems from concern for how
increased speed coupled with increased
traffic puts children
and the staff that are in our Care at
increa increased risk and we have a duty
to maximize the safety of all who share
the lake thank you thank you any
questions John Cena thank you for your
testimony
I just for a very long period of time I
think you realize the passion behind
many of us here regarding the safety of
Lake Winnipesaukee I've lived on the
lake on a small island adjacent to the
broads for 41 years and have seen it all
mostly the safe and a lot of unsafe I'm
very concerned about increase in speed
limit we have young youngsters and
sailing programs who sail across the
broads and to think about not just one
but maybe two boats traveling at 60
miles five miles per hour and the this
is approximately 150 feet here so you
could have one there and you could have
one there running side by side at 65
miles per hour and then maybe you have
40 children out in small sailboats how
is that that's just not going to work I
think one of the one of the proponents
of the the new law talked about minority
versus majority
yes it is a minority versus a majority
it's just inverse to his proposal
obviously to me and to many others the
majority is we do not want to see this
bill passed the minority is are those
who own these extremely high speed boats
and have one intent which is just to go
fast I own a power boat I go maybe 30
miles an hour maybe 32 I can take my
children water skiing we can go for a
Sunset Cruise we can go tubing we can go
for ice cream how fast you really need
to go so thank you for listening and
thank you for opposing this bill
thank you for your testimony I have two
cards left up next
Miss
Hixson
and the last card Mr Ehrenberg
Miss Hixon thank you hello my name is
ananya Hickson I'm from Wolfeboro
prior to the passage of the 45 mile per
hour speed limit Winnipesaukee as you've
heard has suffered from being considered
the cowboy Wild West destination several
fatal and high-profile accidents
involving high-powered speed boats
had contributed to this reputation and
this is why over 300 businesses signed
on to supporting the speed limit law
speed limits on the lake have made a
remarkable difference on the improved
atmosphere of tranquility and safety for
all who recreate there
I take issue with what some have said
about these speedboat drivers being the
safest and most responsible voters one
only has to remember the Fatal Hartman
Littlefield accident the Erica blizzard
accident the 2020 accident where a
kayaker was seriously injured or the
swimmer hit by the speedboat at 65 miles
per hour in 2015.
and you will understand that this is not
necessarily true that these drivers are
the safest and most responsible
a recent study conducted by Dartmouth
College and commissioned by the Lake
Winnipesaukee Association showed that
the lake generates over 17 billion
dollars for the region and the state
Taurus Anglers primary and second
homeowners are attracted to the lake for
its special peaceful Beauty and family
Recreation
they feel safer boating as do we with
the current speed limits why abolish the
speed limits for a select few at the
expense of the majority
marginalizing the majority of family
boaters on the lake is not good for our
local economy
six marinas and boat dealers opposing HB
448 can attest to this
our dollars to our state covers
have been these uh I'm sorry our economy
thrives on tourism
and which contributes millions of
dollars to our state coffers it is in
part why New Hampshire needs no sales
tax
I urge you to vote
inexpedient to legislate on this
Reckless and dangerous bill
and just a more personal note I just I
don't want my children and my
grandchildren to be exposed to these
dangers and without a speed limit I will
move to a different Lake and have my
friends and family come elsewhere thank
you
thank you any questions
seeing none thank you very much my last
good afternoon Kurt Ehrenberg I'm
speaking for myself my regular job here
is a state director for the Humane
Society of the United States but I grew
up going to summer camp on Lake
Winnipesaukee
Ken's Camp I can uh I I just want to say
is someone who uh
grew to love this state as a child
through the Natural Beauty on Lake
Winnipesaukee this is a terrible idea
so please vote this Bill
itl thank you
thank you
I don't have any more pink cards is
there anyone present that hasn't filled
out a pink card that wishes to speak
I'll ask one more time anybody present
that wishes to speak that hasn't filled
out a pink card
seeing none and no one approaching the
mics I'm going to declare this hearing
closed I'm going to give the members of
our committee a few minutes if you wish
to review and look at all the written
testimony you have my clock says it's 2
40. I'll bring us back to take an exact
session at around 2 44 and if you need
more time at that time you can tell me
but take a four minute break look at all
the written materials and we'll be back
can I ask the committee members to take
their seat so I can reconvene the exact
session
so it's 247 members have had a chance to
read the written testimony and to
reflect upon the bill
hb448 I'm going to call the executive
session on
hb448 to to order I believe
representative Ryan you have a motion
you'd like to make
thank you yes sir I do I make a motion
to it all this Bill thank you do I have
a second
seconded by representative Vale
representative Ryan would you like to
speak to your motion yes please
is Bill 448 would raise the j-time speed
limit from 45 miles an hour to 65 on
Lake Winnipesaukee in this area
specifically designated as the broads
and Loosely defined in the bill by some
charted navigational references
a similar version failed in a prior
session with little support the
committee received hundreds hundreds of
emails in opposition and direct
testimony from Marine Patrol Coast Guard
captains and dozens of Lake residents
Property Owners summer camps marinas
Lake Associations and interest in
parties in all aspects of this bill the
largest and fastest boats at the high
speeds are better suited for open Waters
of the ocean no marinas or watercraft
Merchants spoke or otherwise testified
in favor of this legislation after
thorough examination of the safety
recreational environmental and
individual freedoms aspects on both
sides and all of your testimony
heartfelt taking thank you for your time
we felt that we unanimously felt the
current regulations are sufficient and
allow respectful safe and peaceful
enjoyment of Lake by all and protect the
users of this important natural resource
and the citizens who enjoy the lake
thank you representative Veil do you
next is that we heard overwhelming
testimony that this would not be felt to
be safe by people who have been
long-standing
um people living on the lake businesses
operating all of the things that we find
special about New Hampshire where a lot
of children come from other states to go
to camp and we really need to think
about the will of
just a few people and what can happen
when we have such a large lake and a
diversified
place where everyone can recreate
so and then one more thing is I'm a fan
of the loons and I don't like watching
The Loon Cam and seeing the
The Nest swamped
after weeks and weeks of watching these
creatures
do their darnest to try to survive in
2023 so thank you so much thank you Mr
chair
thank you representative anyone else
wish to speak on the motion to itl
representative wolf
thank you Mr chairman the members of the
committee
um many people spoke about this being a
selective Bill and not supporting the
majority
I have to tell you I got 701 emails
against this I'm going to miscountered
there were either one or two in favor so
in supporting my constituents I have to
vote itl
thank you representative anyone else
wish to speak on the motion of itl
Representative arung
thank you very much much Mr chairman and
I do want to thank every member of the
public that came out today to speak on
this bill and all those that sent very
concise and personalized emails it makes
a huge difference than getting a form
letter email about a certain position so
I do want to thank you for that and I do
want to thank our committee leadership
for agreeing to exec this bill directly
after the public hearing so it can be
disposed of quickly and people can get
back to their their calm routine thank
you
thank you representative anyone else
wishing to speak on the motion to itl
seeing no one's hands raised I'm going
to ask the clerk to call the roll
yes
Julia if you can hold on one second I
think we're going to turn your mic off
thank you
um
representative wolf
yes
representative McHugh yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Vale yes representative
is oh he's not here
must be absent okay
representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
Hoyt yes
representative LaMontagne yes
representative Lovett yes representative
Ryan yes please and representative harp
yes so that's 20 for itls zero against
18 18 18. do we have consent would we
put that on consent everyone says yes so
we'll put the itl on the consent agenda
I again like my fellow Representatives
thank all of you for coming here today
and having the opportunity to speak to
us we really appreciate hearing from you
in person that concludes our exact
session and I'll declare this session